we have some breaking news here we're  expecting details on Boeing Boeing will  halt its max production in January this  is according to Dow Jones Boeing of  course falling right now in after-hours  trading after this report that the  production of the 737 max will be  suspended  there had been debate within Boeing  about whether they would slow production  or whether they would hit the pause  button some with some saying that  hitting the pause button would be less  disruptive in the end right and we  should also point out that a lot of the  suppliers you have hundreds of suppliers  rely on Boeing Spirit AeroSystems and  quite a few others down also here in  post market trading  you